今日は炎上せ月にドクター初部だ
今日は炎上しないことを願いますみなさんガラスというものをご存じだろうか王子に
住んでいる人ならわかると思うんですけども大変の良いにはガスが使われています
マートという部分にどんなものかといいますと壁とは違って透明なんですよね透明なん
ですけど丈夫なので太陽の光とかも見えたり外の景色が見えたりすると言うなんかすっ
げ当たり前のこと言ってるんですけども知らない
と言いませんよねー
割愛ガラスって硬いんですそう
普通我々につけるのガラスを破壊することはできることもないですねできることもない
んですけども
はさみハサミでからきれないですよですがそんなガラスをハサミで切れる方法がある
らしいんです
ネットで調べたんですけどねそうなんか水に入れない状態だっ
徒歩てハサミで切るとガラスってヒビが入ると針ブレーンで一気に壊れるんですよです
が水の中で水の中で鋏で柄双方やると綺麗に切れるみたいな情報があるらしいですが
競って酸素をシリコンでできてるらしいんですよ
で水は saas とし旅行小中話す力があるらしくてね高分子レベルの話なんです
けどもささみでからそう
いうとかバリバリってなるんですけども水の中たとこのがらせの分社の間に水が減る
ことによってこそ
やりましょう野党が早い
早速水れていきましょう
はいこちらを使っていきますこれか遊びたのが楽なんですけども今日でから普段て
はさみで切るがすごい大変だと思うんですよ
[音楽]
辺見決め切る
これこれからそむりながらちょっと無理ですね
は連打メリダ愛だけですのでこっちがガラスのポッポ伝えます君が入ってても使えない
のでこれを実験に使いましょうパリーンであるともないと普通にやるといきます
みたいなを
ああ
まずだね普通は式ガス通った付で廃校いう観点だがめちゃくちゃな生まれ形になっ
ちゃうのが市場で終わった時ですですがこれを水の中でやるとどうなるのでしょうか
見てみましょう相手は早速切っていきましょうこの倍になるのを3個も長く使うと本当
に綺麗に切れるみたいな
では切ってみます水
所ばっじますっ
[音楽]
持った
た
なんでこれだから地上で言っても中で機とかは無いやんけ
あればこちらへと飛ぶなればちょっと違うのかな
あ確かに
[音楽]
しれるまためっちゃ近くないと分からないと思うんですけどいきますねー
follow あこのちょっと米答弁で見えるかわかんないですけど
あ切れる月れますね
某次ぐ市場できるとですよ
アーちゃんのはさみが切ったところだけきれいに切れますね
ホラーマップ立つこれを大
おお凄い凄いサクサク切れる
たいときでちょっと疑ってるんですけどもうネットに増えちゃったことは本当のよう
ですガラスのコップは水の中でハサミで切るときれいにスタッフ土地れることが分かり
ました
使う場面はあるのでしょうか
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ